the same people who are very vocal on
trans rights
also tend to be very dismissive of
parentheses non-opportunistic
self-identification as black by some
white people
considering that unlike gender race has
very little basis in biology
shouldn't they be more open to such
self-identification if anything
watch the catch and the question doesn't
um
allude to it but of course dawkins um
dawkins lost an award
given to him 20 years ago i think by the
what is it the american humanistic
association or something
um because he basically tweeted
this this observation um he just put
these two observations side by side
that um we're not allowed to um
to engage the question of transracialism
but we're obliged to accept
transgender as um discuss and this
rears its ugly head with some regularity
i'm trying to remember back in 2017
there was an academic who published a
paper
on this issue and found herself
cancelled over it
i'm trying to remember who that was but
uh in any case first of all i do want to
correct one thing
the idea yeah you do know exactly what
i'm gonna say the idea
that race has very little basis in
biology is
both true and false the implication of
it is false
um what we call race is the
bastardization
of a that's what i thought it was
yeah rebecca touvelle in hypatia wrote
in defense of transracialism back in
2017.
sorry um so what we call race
is a bastardization of a real thing
which might be called population or
lineage depending upon how
uh what scale you want to look at it and
it is a bastardization that is itself
born of racism in other words the idea
of race is a weaponized version of an
objective concept
said the objective concept captures
if if we talk about whether or not you
can
correctly detect somebody's ancestry
when you
encounter them you know on the street in
general we're pretty good and the
problem is you can't tell what
fraction of somebody is from africa or
from asia or
europe um but you can in general tell
that you know if somebody is
predominantly from asia it's not hard to
recognize that and that's not your mind
tricking you that's actual
phenotype derived from genes that come
from a different population
some of that's going to be adaptive skin
color
is an adaptation to uv radiation
and the darkness of skin is an
adaptation to how directly the uv
radiation comes through the atmosphere
if it comes through at a big slant you
don't need very much melanin to protect
you
if it comes in very directly because
your ancestors are from the equator
then you need more melanin to insulate
your genes from
mutation but in any case
the um the real reason that we
do apparently take seriously the idea of
switching
sexes which is not something that one
can actually just simply elect to do
it's not possible whereas we somehow bar
the very same concept when it comes to
uh to race even though at some level
that's much more plausible because lots
of people exist
between races by virtue of hybridization
and therefore how you identify
we all agree is to some degree up to you
right and the problem is at the extremes
we don't agree
with that which is inconsistent um
but in essence it goes back to what we
were talking about in the
first hour podcast which is
that effectively the rule the unwritten
rule of this game
is we will accept those things that put
people we decide should have an
advantage
uh at advantage and we will reject the
very same logic when it would give an
advantage to people that we don't want
to give an advantage so this is
basically all about logical cheating
and that's the reason for the
inconsistency there's so much to say
here
um just a few things to add
we have two words over in sex territory
we have sex and gender
and there are a lot of people um who are
saying
gender isn't real it's a totally made-up
thing no as we've said
over and over and over again gender is
real gender is and we have slightly
different
um versions of this understandings of
what it is
it's called sex role when it's not
humans it's the behavioral manifestation
of sex
um you know sex and sex is
binary and in all species with genetic
sex determination
uh which is to say uh if you have sex
chromosomes as mammals do and as birds
do and as some other clades do as well
immutable you cannot change sex um there
are species that can change sex
clownfish famously
um it doesn't it has not happened there
appears to be a mechanistic block on it
actually happening in species which had
a sex determination
um so in species that are are sexual
as we are in 500 million years of
uninterrupted sexuality in our lineage
alone um we use the term gender to
describe
basically the software part of of sex
and that's more the language that you
tend to use the sex is the hardware and
and gender is the software of sex yep
yep and um
and gender will be a lot more fluid you
know gender if sex is binary gender
you know likely to be strongly bimodal
but it won't be it won't be binary
and given the complexity given how many
things go
into describing how it is that you're
manifesting in the world
it shouldn't be shocking to us to
recognize that sometimes people's
internally
understood sense of what their sex is is
a mismatch for what sex they
actually are and so we call them trans
transgender right um interestingly you
know
race does not have two sets of words
right like
you know so race is a deeply imperfect
proxy
for a real biological phenomenon which
we call as you say population or lineage
but maybe precisely because
there are real fundamental differences
on average
between the sexes and while there
presumably are some differences between
races they are
much more vague and in koat and much
more
mixed because we have a human history of
all sorts of intermixing
right like we all come from an equal
number of male and female ancestors
um but each one of us with the exception
of the very very rare people who are
intersex
um are one or the other um and we all
come
from you know a mother and a father
whereas race is a messier proposition
right so
um you know you could
you could say you know what i'm going to
honor you know
someone someone who is tr who is who's
biracial
um could say i'm going to honor my you
know
german lineage as opposed to my
afro-caribbean lineage in
this thing that i'm doing and i'm going
to identify more over here
that you know and like that's that's a
choice it's a legitimate choice that
people can make
but what we don't tend to allow is
i know of no thing in my particular
history that is asian but i'm going to
call myself asian
and i think you know why why would we on
the other hand
um it does it becomes confusing then at
the point that we say
but you can do that when it comes to sex
and
maybe it's more obviously a problem for
those of us who are thinking deeply
about this precisely because
lineage is real do you know for sure you
don't have any asian in your past
how can any of us know right you know or
native american or
african you know we all have african in
our past but it depends on how far back
you're going right
so um so they re race and sex are just
fundamentally different and they're not
fundamentally different because
race is entirely a social construct and
sex isn't which is the place that you
started yeah they're fundamentally
different
um because we all have male and female
ancestors and we all
are one with the tiny number of
exceptions people who are intersex
whereas race is this inter-interpolating
um you know often uh retrogressing
set of lineages um the differences
between which
um grow more and more um less and less
distinct
the longer we move into a globalist
society
absolutely um interestingly i think
you know the one drop rule is an attempt
to take
race and make it binary which it is
inherently not because you can have
effectively
uh you know any ratio
of races and our
sense of
so you have a continuous variable that
is race and we
have a racist past of attempting to make
it binary
and uh we have the opposite thing taking
place in sex space where we have
something that is inherently binary
and you have this force attempting to
make it continuous
and the point is okay those are actually
mirror images
of each other you've revealed that
you're not working with logic
yeah um that this is entirely
ideology-based yeah you're cheating
uh logically speaking yeah
[Music]
you